– Yara?
– Ja?
– Lisa hat mir gesagt,
dass Selma bald Geburtstag hat.
– Selma?
– Eine Freundin von mir.
Ich möchte ihr etwas schenken.
– Aha.
– Ich möchte ihr ein Fahrrad schenken.
– Was?
Das kannst du dir doch gar nicht leisten.
– Es muss ja auch kein neues Fahrrad sein.
– Du meinst ein gebrauchtes?
– Ja, ich schenke ihr
ein gebrauchtes Fahrrad.
– Das ist aber immer noch ziemlich
teuer für ein Geburtstagsgeschenk.
– Ich möchte Selma überraschen.
– Das ist wirklich nett von dir.
Aber du solltest vielleicht mehr Zeit
mit der Suche nach einer Arbeit verbringen.
– Mach dir keine Sorgen.
Ich finde bald etwas.
– Bestimmt.
Bis dahin musst du deinen Freundinnen
eben preiswerte Geschenke kaufen.
– Bitte, Tante Yara.
Du kannst doch bestimmt ein …
gebrauchtes Fahrrad finden.
Ich zahle dir das Geld auch
so schnell wie möglich zurück.
– Wann ist denn der Geburtstag?
– Bald.
Ich finde es heut noch heraus!
– Na schön.
– Danke, danke, danke,
danke, danke, danke!
– Ja. Ja, ist gut. Und jetzt pack mit an!